now defeating Islamic state will not end
jihadist terrorism that's according to a
new report out this morning it's warning
there are as many as 15 hardline
militias ready to replace is in Syria
alone it comes just days after their UN
Security Council agreed a roadmap for
peace in the country well I joined now
by the former lib dem leader lord
campbell he's in Edinburgh studio in a
very good morning to you um worries
worrying stuff isn't it Tess so I think
we kind of knew this didn't we that even
if is in its current form is obliterated
militarily jihadism will remain I think
we've got to accept that and we've got
it accept it for the foreseeable future
me it's a bit like dragon's teeth as it
were every time you take the head off
one body others spring up and of course
that's why the proposals in the Security
Council resolution you referred to a
moment ago are so important and maybe
we'll discuss the extent of which they
do or do not contain all the necessary
ingredients in a moment nonetheless it's
very important that there should be a
diplomatic political initiative going
hand in hand with the military methods
which are being used in particular the
bombing of Isis well you've raised it
let's discuss it right now I mean is it
enough of a roadmap there have been fine
sounding words and resolutions before
the issue of course with something as
complex as as Syria is making any of the
diplomacy actually happen you're quite
right remember the second resolution
there was one a few weeks ago which used
the expression all necessary means which
is normally used to indicate that
military methods military action can be
used but there was no Express authority
for that the resolution which was passed
a couple of days ago is as you say a
roadmap a framework it's very ambitious
that imagines talks beginning in january
it imagines that democratic elections
could be held within 18 months and of
course the one thing which is almost a
Goering is the gap in
any reference to Assad and the future of
Assad which of course has enormous
importance in relation to Russia's
attitude to these matters absolutely and
I mean from a sad I wanted to ask you
about you know where you stand on you
know even the Russian position or or
points in between is what happened in
Libya and perhaps Iraq before it's a
lesson for the future there the
pragmatic way forward and that you
remove the strong leader the unpalatable
to say the least leader but then what
happens is the Libyan situation and an
awful vacuum into which all kinds of
things flow should we get over the
obsession in the short term about us
Assad well it was interesting philip
hammond speaking further fonseca d
speaking at the United Nations Security
Council debate just the other day was
very robust in this condemnation of
Assad but it's believed that the British
government's position is that there
should be a temporary role and no more
than that the Russians on the other hand
take are much more Pro a sad position I
mean remember that the Russians attitude
towards Assad is not out of any sense of
friendship it's in reference to their
own particular interest they want to
maintain the naval base at tattoos of
the Mediterranean and of course the
military base which they've established
at Latakia and they then see for the
moment at least that Assad is the most
important factor in allowing them to
continue that and of course as a result
to have influence over seat of the top
table but to have influence and the
outcome of the Middle East issues well
what's your take on it I mean what's
your assessment what would end as much
of the conflicts can be ended most
quickly and stop for instance the
terrible suffering of the people of
Syria the flow of refugees if Assad said
right I'm going next week would that be
a good thing or a bad thing well I think
it would take everyone by surprise if he
were to say something of that kind and
in fact i'm not sure the Russians would
let him and we have also to recognize
that he enjoys very civil support from
tehran from the iranian government
and indeed there are Iranian forces at
work on behalf of the Assad regime in
Syria itself no I think a phased
withdrawal would almost certainly be the
best possible outcome but as it's often
been pointed out in relation to Syria
and again and cross the last two or
three days look there is no ideal
solution here what one's got to do is to
try and get the best possible solution
available and I think some temporary
role for Assad would be part of the
stability which is necessary for
transition if you were to go back to the
point you made a little earlier then
that would create a vacuum which others
might seek to take advantage of and I
just wanted to ask you finally while you
with a slaw Campbell I don't think we've
spoken since you were a noble band
congratulations on that but you'll take
then on this some this issue of House of
Lords reform and things like the over 80
s being removed from it haha well I have
to confess I'm 74 so perhaps i should
declare an interest I my view is that
the House of Lords should be eighty
percent directly elected and that there
should be a balance of twenty percent so
you can put in people with particular
expertise scientists environmentalists
doctors people of that kind but the fact
that I've joined the club doesn't mean
that I don't think the club ought to be
reformed very well put mint gamble or
gamble thank you very much pleasure
thank you